クリーチャーはずめ雪道です太平洋もた縮めたでしょ
格差第一面お待たせいたしました100万円-9
たい何だっけまぁでもなんでこの終盤の気がせんですよね100万曲
第8弾100万円で
こちらのどうかいます
なんでこんな遅くなったかというとあのめっちゃ届くのが遅かったです
なんか甘酢を見てたんですよ amazon で僕は何でも買うんでアマゾン pp て
みてたら
てロンド売ってるなーと思ってあーこれですね95万1000円+が配送料が5万円で
ぴったり約100万円でございますどこに見て2号車日が7月7日
なんですけど届いてるのか最近なんでも3ヶ月ちゃいまったんですよ
届けてくれてありがとうございましたもう寸前に気になりました amazon で
100万円の方の購入すること自体珍しいんでちょっと様好奇心であどんな方が届くの
かなと思って買ってみたんですけど
さすがと言うべきがまずででかいです
teame
はい
[音楽]
数で処分するかどうしたらこういうシーンさと思います
というこう答えていてみましょう
おおおおおおおおおお
[拍手]
すごいか
ええええええ
おっん
bejean
ん
[音楽]
はぁ
ブーバパパだぴょんさんヌー
ですねーみてください芽が出てきました
ん
[音楽]
wh
ズレましたーーーこれが顔ですねさすが100ないんですクオリティーが高いですはい
というわけでパーツが全部出たところで1回頭と体を合体させてみましょういいで90
キロあるんでめっちゃ大変です
そうです
me
7ん
味は好き
[音楽]
ん
ああああああ
ああああああああ
legare どうぞ本当に明治のイメージだとホントこういう感じになる予定なん
ですけどさせが100万円というべきか
1人だととてもじゃないけど持ちませんちょっと仲間を呼んできます
ぞぉっ
なんだあああああ
起きません
オートでかいんだよ
まず次回は果実
実物です実際にじゃあのど飴言ったらこのサイズですかはいという気でティラド
男性じゃ
あって言ったそういう3人の力を合わせて玄関の上までグッズ持っていい
あとは人類わー
恐竜と髪はそんなことに
どういう顔をするか見ていくときです
さーああああ
[音楽]
うん
冬
p 主
いいし
なんとかプテラノドン喧嘩ままでもできます大脳当選人での本ですけど
新労働キツかったですこれから人類を玄関に呼んでくるんでリアクションを見てみた
じゃんよ
ちょっと見てもらっていいかねまーす
カフェ
た
すべてえっ
魔術かぺかぺるのっすごくないです
こんなできるのが覚めたのか
re した
dec 4
voodoo
洞窟1くれた
mar
砂糖信頼のプテラノドンでござっ
やはり準備は同様覚醒のようですねー
[音楽]
ばーんわー
me
al
uh
山田ねこれは
これは止まない